la Nouvelle-Zélande sous les eaux dans
le nord du pays cette plaine est
complètement submergée par les pluies
torrentielles la nuit dernière a été
particulièrement agitée
ça ne ressemble à rien de ce que j'ai
connu avant c'est vraiment au-dessus de
tout cette nuit il y a du tonnerre des
éclairs c'était effrayant
depuis dimanche le pays à la fougère est
durement frappé par la tempête Gabriel
après une traversée du Pacifique Sud ce
cyclone a été rétrogradé au rang de
tempête en s'approchant des côtes né aux
zélandaises des vents pouvant atteindre
140 km/h et des cumules de
précipitations jusqu'à 20 cm en 24
heures le Premier Ministre en poste
depuis seulement trois semaines à
décréter l'état d'urgence le troisième
de l'histoire du pays
cela signifie que nous mettrons tout en
œuvre pour être sûr que nous apportons
le plus de soutien possible à la
population la Force de Défense est
actuellement sur le terrain
la porte un soutien logistique important
en est dans aux évacuations des
évacuations rendues difficile par les
dégâts subis par les infrastructures
partout dans le pays les axes routiers
sont inondés ou coupés par des
glissements de terrain les habitants se
retrouvent isolés coincés dans des
maisons envahies par louer la boue plus
de 100000 personnes restent privées
d'électricité le gouvernement a promis
une enveloppe de près de 7 millions
d'euros pour réparer les habitations
endommagées après une journée de mardi
agité la Nouvelle-Zélande devrait
bénéficier d'une accalmie mais selon les
spécialistes le pays est plus exposé que
jamais assez phénomènes extrêmes
alimentés par le dérèglement climatique